it's the bootleg cab podcast we got a
special guest in here very special guest
come on now he brought a cigar I brought
a joint TK Kirkland is here what's up
everybody he's back yes welcome man
thank you Pam well listen we were just
talking about how you thought uh my
co-host James uh is very unhealthy by
the way I walk he gives you unhealthy
Vibes yes he does what was it about my
walk that you've seen it looked
unhealthy and that you was gonna die
this year damn don't take care of your
health well yeah you know what cause I
don't go to doctors at all I haven't
been in like a decade yeah that's not
that's not that's not that's not good
fam the other thing about James is James
is um I've like been working with him
about two years the entire time
he works out every morning and he he
work out every morning every morning but
he stays the same weight he's not
working out no I'm working out he got my
Apple Fitness and he tells you how many
calories no no you ain't working out
[__] I don't know who you lying to
[Music]
I see I could see you going in the gym
walking around looking at looking at
equipment and touching it like this like
I can see you doing this like I went you
know I see you touching yeah
you went to the gym so how much weight
you lost uh so I lost 100 pounds before
the pandemic gained all that back now
lost about 40. okay so so listen stop
playing with your weight stop going up
and down
and the reason why I talked because I've
been on this planet a long time I've
seen so many people when they fluctuate
with their weight right and what happens
is that to me what I've seen it causes
Strokes laid on Down the Line it causes
um heart attacks because that's stress
on your heart
going up and going down you know what I
mean and this is something I think is um
like we was all off the air I I think
this is a great thing to talk about
health because we always talk about
music
we always talk about relationships but
we never money talk and talk about money
but we never talk about health and we
want to teach these kids and women and
everybody start going to the doctor
let's let's start putting that out in
the universe that we take care of
ourselves you know so that's important
oh an hour a day you're gonna walk up
and down the street I got your word I
got 100 when I come back in a year he's
gonna win the same
take your clothes off you want your
woman to be looking at you look sexy see
if you want to do it for yourself you're
married
so I'm gonna give you a game watch this
I am sexy I'm gonna give me some games
I want you I want you to buy some nice
pajamas okay and some house shoes and
wear a robe
around the house
watch this [__] it may sound crazy but
you're gonna look like a king when you
open the door and somebody other door
you've presented you extremely well
right instead of coming to the door with
slides on socks and shorts and a t-shirt
somebody I come to work yeah
everything you do is your presentation
right and you want to have class and the
reason why I'm sharing I'm living on the
air because now when people see you in a
nice pair of pajamas you maybe have a
glass of water in your hand some fake
glasses put it together you're getting
lined up you're looking good right
so get a nice robe some nice house shoes
cut your hair yeah
keep you keep your line up take care of
yourself we'll get your pajama game
together get your roll together
give me an example of how this just we
are just tearing down James
when Biggie with puffy okay I think it
was just a [__] and puppies girl at the
time told puffy to put that [__] in
some fly-ass [__] and when he started
performing with the hat this is the
glasses everything nobody was rocking
Versace till biggie wolf's side 100 and
he became like a same thing with Ross I
know females who are like sexually
obsessed with Rick Ross yep
he's a overweight man who's very but
it's his presentation his attitude yes
there's girls who are [__] I know one
girl in particular who's like number one
in her spank bank is Rick Ross and I
don't get it wow yep I see it shout out
to Ross but he does have a certain when
he puts suits on the [__] looks smooth
in the [__] that's the same
thing like with the robe man you gotta
do you guys You Gotta Wear that belly
with pride
of my belly yes right what you mean yeah
you'll be talking about my sweaters with
a button-up shirt wide open wife beater
no no don't go do that show it show it
up show it yeah yeah but hell hell I
want you to be here every time I come I
wonder like yo T
when I come back in a year you better
have been the doctor three times
three I guess every three months here's
what I want you to do and we're gonna
we're gonna go
two things I want you to do there's a
Thing Called Life Line Screening okay
you heard of it Lifeline screening is a
diagnosis of a doctor when you go in
they put these different things on you
right and they could tell you if you uh
lie before a stroke heart attack they
see how the blood is going through your
body and you they send that in the mail
you take that to your doctor because
doctors only ask you what is hurting you
right they don't go inside and check all
that that's what you want you want to go
Lifeline screening right and I guarantee
you they're gonna save your life yeah
because you ain't been to the doctor in
10 years yeah
all right well we out we got to get
James to the doctor we gotta go